最後の四つの瞑想 で そこは今日は説明はしませんだけど
アビダンマのところで心のところで私は明確にこの禅定のことを説明しましたから
まだ繰り返しはしたって意味がないんです
今はこのサマーディ瞑想の中で今まで説明したのは
いくらか色界の禅定の瞑想と仏教的な瞑想と
仏教の純粋な仏教だけ発見した瞑想の場合は
この第一禅定が生まれてこないんです
こちらのチャート見ればわかります
例えばアーハレパティクーリサンニャ
食べるものは不浄なものだと観察することは
これ仏教だけやっているものなんですね
やはり仏教だけでやっている瞑想は
必ずしも智慧が発達するためであって
煩悩をなくすためであって
人格は成功成長するための瞑想なんですね
ただ あの 何と言いますか
なんとか神秘体験を得たければというだったら
世の中ではいくらでも瞑想あるんですね
本当は神秘体験というのは幻覚だと仏教で言ってるし
それだったらいくらでも方法あるんだと
その中でこの禅定を作れる瞑想というのは自引きチャート
アナパーナサティとかね
それからこのいろいろ見て瞑想するところですね
それぐらいですね チャートで全部明確にありますからね
禅定生まれる瞑想と禅定生まれない瞑想
二つに分けてみてください
禅定生まれない瞑想はわざわざ仏教が紹介している瞑想なんですね
だからはっきり私の個人の意見で言うならば
禅定生まれる瞑想よりは禅定が生まれない瞑想の方にチャレンジした方がいいんです
それは観察でもあるし
考えることでもあるし
物事を理解することでもあります
またちょっと質問です
アヌスサティとサティが違うんだって仰ってましたよね
前回も今回も そしたらサティパッタナーマのサティっていうのはどっちかなのか
それとも両方なのか 周縁中の
サティパッタナーマのサティはサティなんですね
アヌスサティではない
ここに書いてあることはアヌスサティとは違う
この無色界の瞑想 何かものを何かに頼って
とにかく人は禅定状態を作る
そこで最終的に心が統一というレベルに止まっちゃうんですね
喜悦感もないし ただシャだけで統一感で止まっちゃうんですね
そこで主体客体の状態も消えてるんですね
消えてるんだけど 自分がいるという実感がはっきりとあります
で それからこの第五禅定まで進んだ人にとっては
さらに瞑想を続けたければ一つしか方法ないんです
一番目はアーカーサーなんちゃらというのは
で 瞑想してこの第五番目に行った人にとっては
この喜悦感 快楽感 何もないんです
ただ何も感情ない その楽しみ
いわゆる平安な気持ちだけ
だから心で何か掴まってるかというと
これはすごい掴まっている状態でもないんですね
また自分消えたと思いましょう
自分消えたんだけど なんとなく自分が力強く
この心の働きだけあります
でも何も感情の波もない
楽しみもない 喜悦感もない
苦しみもない その状態からいわゆる分かりやすく言えば空無辺と言うしか方法ないんだけど
何もない この空間という
いわゆるスペースですね
スペースでとったらものすごい幅広いんですね
そこを心で認識しようとするんです
スペース自体を そこは普通に人間できます
普通の人間はスペースは認識しないんです
スペースは推測します
我々は現象を認識できます
空間の認識できません
すごい不安になっちゃうんですよ
空間なくなっちゃったら
上も下もどちらでもない場合はね
例えばね 私たちは宇宙空間のどこかにいるとすると
どういう状態ですかね
何も比較するもの何もないですよね
どこにいるかと 上見たっても真っ暗
前見たっても真っ暗 後ろ見たっても真っ暗と
それで星見えるかもしれませんだけど
上見ても星 右左どこを見ても星だけで
あれショックで死んじゃうかもしれません
普通だったら落ちるぞと怖がったりするんだけど
これまあこちら下見たら空だから落ちるんだからって言って
どこに逃げる？逃げるとこはないと
ですからこの まあその場合もやっぱり目には一応空間
壁が出ます まあ例えば宇宙に飛んでみたっても
星なんか見たっても やっぱり暗闇でちゃんと壁が作ってくれるんです
なんとなくそこまで そこはまあ壁ですよっていう感じにありますけどね
でも本当の空間ではね
そういう壁とか何もないんですね
そうやってこの空間というものを認識するんですね
これやっぱりサマーディ瞑想を進んで終了しなきゃできないんですね
で そこでサマーディがまた生まれる
それにはこの無色界の一番目
他の瞑想法ないんです
それしか それもいくらかの物質に頼っていること
物質ない状態に頼っていますけど
それも物質の次元ですけどね
次に そこを認識した自分の心が
心には次元がないんだと
何の次元もないんだと
時間的な次元もないし
空間的な次元もない 認識するんだから
この心の働きにまた働きを集中して 第2番目に入っちゃうんです
それで じゃあまあ 第2番目の禅定では
心には 心は宇宙空間と同じだと
上下も前も後ろも何もないんだと
過去も現在も未来も何もない働きだと
次に この心もなくしてない状態
これまあそれしか説明できません
これはね 本当に難しいんですけどね
なぜ難しいかと 我々に空間さえ認識できませんから
空間認識できるのは禅定が終わった人なんです
空間認識できた人にとっては
心の無限さというか この無量というかね
この心 心も同じく この前も上も後ろも何もないということで
何も存在しない 存在はあるんだけど
なんか変ですね それでもそこは認識する
次にこれ これもない 心もなしにして
本当にないということを認識するんですね
だからないということを認識するのは大変難しい
そこで三番目の禅定が生まれるんです
そういうのは一つできたらね
ちょっともうズルズルとできるんです
そこにそのレベルに行ったらね
だから何もない 心もない状態
心も働けない状態 空間も働かない状態
認識できた人にとっては
次にそれ以上心にはもうどうしようもないんです
そこに心の気のもう最小限に小さくしてみる
いわゆる心があるかないかとなる
なんとなく心がサンニャーあるようでまたないようで
もうそのところまで持っていくんですね
それで終わり 瞑想の世界
それ以上は不可能です
そういう説明は仏教の世界だけしかないんです
世の中で仏教の瞑想よりはすごい他の瞑想はかなり盛んですけど
こういう風にちゃんと心理学的に分析して発見してわかっているテキストはないんですね
でもお釈迦様もこのお釈迦様だけではなくて
他の人々もね こういう禅定なんかは体験していましたよとね
ああ言ってありましたけど
なかなかテキストないのは不思議なんですけどね
だからヒンドゥーの世界でもね
何かテキストあった方が正しいなのにない
ということは 本物の禅定ある人々はくだらんことを喋らなかったでしょう
だからテキストはみんな禅定も偉そうに教えてやるぞということだから役に立ちませんよ
本物の人は何も喋れないということで
喋るためにはこのもう想像する知恵が必要なんですね
だからお釈迦様は喋っちゃったんです
言葉で説明できますよと
みんな理解するかしなか置いといて
後の人々でもね 科学やらいろんな哲学やら思考はね
どんどん成長して成長していると
お釈迦様の言葉はね 知識次元でも理解できる可能性はありますから
そこで四つの四十種類の瞑想の世界終了いたします
ほんのちょっと四時半までですか
ではまあ休み取ろう取ろうと思ったんだけど
一応四十終わる  この方の時計が前方に私の目から見える大きい時計
私のところの時計はあるんだけど
見えるでしょ ね